Cold email is responsible for some of
the fastest client acquisition in the
agency space and it's even more powerful
in 2026 if you know how to use AI right.
So to show you guys how I brought on Sav
who was able to generate over half a
million dollars in sales opportunities
in just 6 months as a full-time student
with no sales background. So today he's
going to be sharing the word forword
copy that he used to land his first
clients through cold email. How he uses
a simple four-step automation to
personalize at scale. The zerorisk offer
framework that gets strangers to
actually respond to cold emails. and his
full process for building lead lists
using niche databases that most people
don't even know exists. And like I said,
he built all of this with his girlfriend
Alexandra in six months. So, I hope that
you guys enjoy and learn something new.
All right, Sav. So, you generated over
half a million dollars in sales
opportunities through only cold
outreach. I'm really excited to have you
here today and super excited to talk
about how you were able to do that. It's
great to meet you, man.
>> Great to meet you, too, Nick. Thanks for
having me.
>> Absolutely. So yeah, you you've thrown
together some resources here to
basically be able to take someone from a
complete beginner to understanding the
theory of cold outreach and I'm really
excited to talk to you about it because
I've never really done cold outreach and
it's not really something that I teach
to my students too well too much because
I don't really do it that much. So I'm
excited to hear kind of like the
insights and I've heard that you've only
really been doing this for like six to
eight months. So that's really really
cool. So excited to dive into the slides
you got here.
>> Yeah, perfect man. I'm really excited to
show you everything. I'm going to walk
through the exact strategy I went to
from zero to one. I'll show some copy.
I'll even talk about like
infrastructure, lead list building,
basically the whole shebang so that
everyone kind of knows exactly what to
do going forward.
>> Absolutely. Yeah. And I see here that it
says that you're also a full-time
student. So, do you want to give a real
quick intro about kind of like your
background and what you're up to now
with your business?
>> Yeah. So I started the business as a
whole during the summer of 2025 and
basically near the tail end is when it
started generating traction but
obviously school started up again. I
actually went to university for
architecture uh landscape architecture.
So literally no relation whatsoever. Um
and then during the school year
basically it was go to class and then
after class um run to either a room, a
cafe or back to my place and then just
you know grind out business for another
couple of hours and things like that. Um
but right now actually uh just to be
candid I am taking like a a gap semester
gap year just since the business has
gained some traction.
>> Absolutely. Yeah. I mean it's just one
of those things you know you only get
this type of opportunity once in maybe a
hundred years if if that. So, um, I love
that and it's it's that kind of like
energy and excitement that really makes
businesses succeed because you were so
excited to leave class and and sprint
somewhere to go work on the business.
So,
>> awesome. Yeah, let me just jump right
into it then. So, building an AI
automation business as a full-time
student. So, basically how I actually
got started, first steps was university
summers. I needed cash. That was
honestly the whole impetus. I don't have
like some crazy origin story or anything
like that. Um, and I did outbound lead
genen. Basically, I learned AI and
automation just by doing. And that's
when I started getting requests from
just friends and family. And originally,
a lot of people, I think, are really
apprehensive about doing free work um
just for one reason or another,
especially if you're a full-time
student. But I definitely saw it as very
strategic because I realized that if
anyone else was going to trust me with
their money, then they would needed to
see that I could actually bring a
return. And it started off with like
really small things, like nothing to
even do with outbound lead genen. It was
just like helping create um a website
and like a booking automation for a
salon for a family member. Um it was
like helping a person who was in like
the medical field integrate some sort of
AI research. And that sounds so much
more fancy than it is. But at the time
people are not even familiar with how to
use these tools like Perplexity or Claw.
They only know Chat GPT. And so just
sitting down with them and teaching them
how to use those tools proved to be
really really beneficial for them. And
once I could prove I could deliver, I
could use them as a case study. And then
I was able to like build trust from
there.
>> Yeah. Yeah. That's huge. You know, the
the thing that I've always thought about
cold outreach and cold email is that
it's kind of hard unless you have some
sort of proof. You know, you have to say
the person has to understand that they
should work with you for a reason. And
so, if you have never done any work
before, you have no case studies, you
have no social proof out there, I feel
like it's really hard. But you can let
me know if if I'm kind of off the mark
there.
>> No. Yeah, you're absolutely right. the
first question anyone's ever going to
ask you, especially if you get them on a
meeting, is where are your case studies?
Where's the proof? And things like that.
And so actually having a I guess like a
rolodex of case studies to actually fall
back on even if they're not necessarily
one for one because like I said like I'm
building like a salon website. I'm you
know helping like medical research and
things like that, but I'm reaching out
to like video production companies and
I'm reaching out on behalf of bealf of
like legen and outbound. And so they ask
me questions, but just the idea that you
can even help other businesses and you
know how to talk to other business
owners, how to integrate your systems
with other businesses that reducing that
level of friction for them is also going
to be massive to actually have someone
trust you and actually, you know, send
you some cash along the way.
>> 100%. So, so just to be clear here, your
kind of first couple case studies that
you were able to do um or your first
couple products you were able to turn
into case studies were kind of like warm
referrals a bit, like friends and
families. you did stuff for them and
then you were able to scale up with cold
outreach once you had that under your
belt.
>> Yeah, exactly. It's like um I'm I'm sure
everyone's seen that YouTube short of
like Alex Herozie talking about how to
get your first customer and it's like
text everyone, text all your friends,
text all your family and that's exactly
what happened. Um, yeah, it's going to
be a little bit weird obviously cuz I'm
sure people feel some type of way about
talking to friends and family about, you
know, getting a business started and
things like that. But there's so many
ways that you can like really take those
case studies and spin it and make it
seem very very valuable and it can be
very very valuable. So like for the
specific beauty salon um where I helped
like create basically a digital presence
for them and set their booking
appointment, uh this was like when they
were first getting their start, right?
And so once I actually was able to do
that for them, they were actually able
to scale like as a solo operator within
a beauty salon, like just one person to
like $10,000 monthly recurring revenue.
And they still continue to do that
today. And so having even if it at the
time it doesn't seem like massive
leverage, doing things like that um have
proven to be like really really
beneficial now because being able to say
that in and of itself gets a lot of
trust from people, right?
>> Absolutely. Absolutely. Yeah. And trust
is the greatest currency you can have
right now.
>> For sure.
Yeah. So, what actually worked when I
was first starting out was not really
endlessly building. I kind of assumed
that there was never going to be like a
perfect product and I wanted to build
later. Um, so I would always sell the
outcome first and only build after a
commitment. And this also allowed me to
test different offers. So, I think this
if anyone takes away one thing from this
presentation, this is the biggest thing
I would have them take away. And it's
really just that classic like speed to
execution kind of framework that a lot
of entrepreneurs talk about. There's so
much information out there uh like your
channel and tons of other uh AI and
automation channels that allow you to
build things out that allow you to you
know test cloud code, test naden, test
make all that great stuff. Um but at the
end of the day, I think a lot of people
get really bogged down by the amount of
things that they can actually build that
they don't actually go out and talk to
customers and try to sell what they
build, right? And it sounds really
harsh, but if you're trying to make a
business out of it and all you're doing
is, you know, building, you don't
actually have a business yet. you kind
of just have like a project or a a a
portfolio of projects or kind of a
hobby. And so what I would do is I would
always like create offers and I knew
outbound existed since then. Um so I
would I knew this was like a really easy
way to test them out and I would create
offers around things that I knew I could
build. So let me like give like a very
pragmatic example or a practical
example. So like on your channel you
have a bunch of videos talking about
like hey like sell this XYZ system for
XYZ dollars, right? and you've been in
the industry for very long. You have
tons of experience and so you've sold
these actual systems. And so it would
behoove me to go out of my way and
figure out or reinvent the wheel and
find systems that I think are going to
work instead of just trusting someone
who's already sold them before for a
bunch of money, right? And so if I know
these systems can be built because you
have the tutorials and the templates and
I know that these systems can be sold
for money because you have the
experience that tons of other people do,
then why not just essentially put that
out into the ether? And if people
actually commit to the actual
investment, they're like, "Okay, like
that sounds interesting." Oh, like lead
genen, outbound, CRM, hiring pipeline,
whatever. Uh, sounds really interesting
proposal generator. Uh, let me, you
know, like, let me pay you for that. Let
me do that. And once they're in the door
and they're willing to pay you for that,
then you can always turn around and
actually build those systems out. And we
have, you know, galaxy brain
intelligence at the tip of our fingers
nowadays. And we have tons of people
like you posting YouTube videos. And so
I think it's really like the ability to
build something is no longer the actual
bottleneck for a lot of people. It's
really just the ability to talk to
customers and see if it's actually going
to be something that they can sell.
Moving forward, um I actually want to
talk about like the exact offer I gave
people. And I was really really
aggressive with it. Um so my offer was
literally you don't have to pay me
anything. You don't even have to sign me
a sign a contract with me. It's going to
be totally free and it's going to be
zero risk. And once I started talking to
companies that weren't just friends and
family because at the end of the day,
like I did I did do free work for them,
but because of their friends and family,
they're going to want to put some cash
in your hand, right? I'm sure everyone's
experienced that. When you're talking to
cold companies and when I hop on the
screen and they see like a 20-year-old
college kid, there's already so much
trust I have to build back up. And so, I
would try to make it as little risk as
possible. And, you know, with you and I
being Asian, we look like 3 years
younger than we really are as well. Um,
>> that is true.
So, what I would essentially say is
like, "Hey, here's like a here's like a
snapshot. There's like a demonstration
of me actually building the exact thing
I want to build for you. You don't have
to pay me. You don't have to you don't
have to sign a contract with me. And I
could even build this entire thing out
and you could just ghost me and I could
waste hours of my time. The only thing I
asked for is the permission to actually
reference their company so I could reach
out to other companies like them who are
probably willing to pay me, right?" And
so literally one of my very first
um people that I reached out to was a
video agency and this was like my very
first client and I reached out to them
with this exact offer. And I'm going to
be honest like um there is like some
level of I guess luck in this game or
opportunity in this game where they I
offered like this completely free offer
for them. And eventually they really
grew to like me and they became like
literally like my first paying client.
They're like, "Hey, like we understand
that you're willing to do this for free,
but we like you. we want to actually pay
you and we enjoy like the fact that
you're actually willing to, you know,
put your skin in the game. And that free
client turned into a paid client and
they literally still work with me like
today even like 6 to 8 months later even
though I was like a complete beginner
and in tandem and I'll talk about this
later as well is I was working with like
another video agency who didn't want to
pay me at the time and I basically spent
like 3 4 hours with them live
demonstrating how the system works. They
had no experience with AI and automation
whatsoever, if not Legion. And I would
have to like literally be on Zoom and I
would like tell them where to click
their mouse and everything like that. It
was a massive uh it was a massive uh
investment on my own time. But at the
end of it, they were so happy. Uh they
they were like happy to give me the
ability to say, "Hey, I helped this
company do this exact outcome or deliver
this exact system." And being able to
literally just put that one extra line
inside of my outbound messaging
immediately like nearly double like my
reply rates and it increased the amount
of meetings I could get. And I think
that that sole case study or that piece
of free work alone probably got me to
the point where I am today. And I don't
think if I I think if I didn't do that,
I would have probably have to wait
months if not, you know, I would have
never gotten there and I would still be
in the same position today. But because
I kind of just like I guess ate that
frog, I was able to kind of um leverage
that as a case study and then get other
people to actually be willing to pay me
for it.
>> Yeah. No, it's super cool that the data
actually shows the increase after you
were able to put that that line in
there. You know, I think a lot of people
at the beginning, they don't think about
it right because they think they're
hopping into this opportunity and if
they don't see money by, you know, the
end of month one, it's they're failing.
But really up front, it's about how can
you prioritize yourself to get reps, to
get experience, to get proof rather than
money. The money will come later on once
you have all that. And it gets easier
and easier once you have more and more.
But it's just one of those things where
it's like you could be the most skilled
n workflow builder in the world, but
with zero experience that kind of just
like evens out your your advantage
there. You know, experience is is what
you need. Experience obviously builds
trust and we just talked about for a
long time how important trust is. So I
love the zero risk offer.
>> Yeah. No, dude, you're absolutely right.
So like like a lot of people who are
probably watching this video, I'm part
of like, you know, school communities
that teach AI and automation like yours.
And basically there was like a point
where I posted and this is probably like
this is how the conversations are,
right? Like I made a post where I was
like, "Oh, like this is how I made half
a million dollars in sales opportunities
inside of instantly." And I remember I
would look at some of the systems that a
lot of people in that community would
build and it was like I could barely
even understand like how they actually
put it all together, you know, like I
felt so technically um behind compared
to them. But the weird thing was a lot
of them were reaching out to me because
they couldn't get like the sales part or
the marketing part, right? They couldn't
generate interest from customers, but
they could spend all day in front of a
computer and build like these massive
massive systems on Naden and make and
use like these agentic workflows, but it
was all kind of just sitting there
collecting dust because they hadn't
actually figured out the part where they
could actually talk to customers and get
their, you know, product or service out
in front of customers.
>> Yeah, that that actually is something
we've been seeing big time in in our
communities as well about like sometimes
like it's it's very rare that you can be
someone that's that's both. If you are,
that's great. But if you're one or the
other and you specialize in that, maybe
just go look to partner with someone
that can, you know, complement you
really well. And then you guys are a
super team. So yeah, what's on the next
slide for us?
>> So next, I kind of want to talk about
like my actual outbound campaign
playbook. Um, this is literally like
everything I do from top to bottom when
I'm actually creating outbound campaign,
not just for myself, but also for my
clients as well. So this is not going to
be just like a a zero to one game, but
this is also something that I hope
people can use for their fulfillment
process as well. And hopefully this is
like something that they can immediately
take action on today. So the first thing
I do is I'll find niche databases. And I
think this is something that people
don't talk about at least not enough. So
nowadays we have like you know GPT
research, we have um Claude which can
also do research and we also have like
research enabled models from the
beginning like perplexity or XAI and a
lot of people when they think about like
hey like what um where do I look for
like my leads they immediately go to
like the classic LinkedIn sales
navigator Apollo or all these other like
huge tools right but a lot of people
don't um aren't aware that there's a
bunch of niche databases that actually
hold the leads that you're looking for
and it's already pre-selected for you.
Right? So, off the top of my head, the
biggest one I know about is like I think
it's called AIA, American Institute of
Architects, right? So, let's imagine you
are doing an outbound campaign targeted
towards architects and your go-to gut
feeling is to go into like Apollo or
these massive leadbased directories and
basically just try and play around with
the filters and hope that a bunch hope
that the lead list that you scrape is
actually going to be all architects
where you could have if you just did a
little bit of research on perplexing
asked like hey like where are some niche
databases that hold a bunch of
architecture companies it would probably
tell you like AIA American Institute of
Architects right and the reason that's
really important is because they've
already done the filtering for there's a
0% chance that inside that list there's
a company that isn't an architecture
firm, right? And so instead of playing
that guessing game, you can just use AI,
spend a couple minutes researching
specific databases, find one that is
already really easily scrapable, and
then now from there you already have
like a perfect list of company domains
that you can just have to pull decision
makers from, which is like the third
step, and basically you already have
like a perfect lead list to start
reaching out to. I think that's like a
really big thing that's a really big
unlock that I think a lot of people
aren't taking advantage of nowadays as
well. And then from there, it's really
just setting up deliverability. So
basically just setting up multiple
domains to ensure emails land. That
basically means like if you have one
domain, you can set up a couple email
accounts. You can't send a thousand
emails from one account. I'm not going
to go too deep into this cuz it's like a
massive rabbit hole. But basically,
instead of sending 3,000 emails from one
account, just set up like a 100 emails
and send 30 emails from each one of
them, and none of them will be marked as
spam and you'll get the same volume out
there. From there, it's crafting
campaign and offers, which we'll talk
about in depth a little bit later. This
is really like the crux of the entire
thing. If this falls flat, then it's
going to be pretty hard. I always lead
with value. So, I always send like a
free video first, which I'll talk about
a little bit more as well, just because
people are nowadays a little bit more
apprehensive to get on a meeting off the
bat. And if you don't give them a little
bit of like a lead magnet, per se,
they're not going to be willing to want
to talk to you. And then obviously, like
with any sort of marketing strategy, you
want to tweak as you go, right? Whether
it's like a paid ad strategy, whether
it's like a UGC strategy or outbound
strategy, uh you take the data that
you've collected from what you did and
then you want to iterate on a weekly,
monthly or bi-weekly basis or something
like that.
>> Gotcha. Yeah. So on that last point, one
thing that I want to ask you about is
how should a beginner know how much to
be doing? because I know that cold email
is is definitely a numbers game. And
there's that story from Hermoszi where
he was putting out flyers on cars and he
was doing like 100 a day, which he felt
was like was a ton, but then his mentor
was like, "Dude, you got to be doing
like a,000, 2,000 a day." So, how did
you get started? You know, what do those
stats look like? How many are you
sending out per day? And then how is
that scaled up?
>> Yeah, that's a great great question. So,
when I first started, I literally bought
one domain. And I wouldn't advise this,
but I I got like five email inboxes
under each cuz I was a broke college
student, so I was just trying to make
ends meet. And I think that means so
what is 30 divi what is 30 times 5? Um
150, right? And basically I would send
out 150 emails a day from these accounts
once they were like fully warmed up and
stuff. But I think I got very lucky to
actually get traction from that level of
volume. Maybe it was my email, maybe it
was my offer obviously, but I think
there's a level of luck that played into
that as well. But honestly, I think for
a beginner starting out, buy three
domains. Um, you'd have 15 inboxes in
total. If you go like for the max
amount, you could put like five dom
inboxes underneath each domain. It's not
advisable. People typically recommend
like two or three, but if you're really
on a budget and you're trying to get as
much volume out there as possible, just
try it out. Um, and that'll allow you to
do basically triple the volume that I
did. So, 450 emails. If you kind of
multiply that out on like a a a monthly
basis, I think that's like uh it's like
nearly 9,000 emails or something like
that. Yeah, like 9,000 emails on a
monthly basis. And if you're reaching
out to 9,000 leads, the way I think
about it, I think about like in terms of
numbers, and you have a decent campaign,
let's say like 5% reply rates, uh 5% of
9,000 is going to be like 450 people are
going to reply back to you. If you have
a decent offer, maybe half of them are
actually interested in what you have to
say. So you have 225 people reaching
back out to you saying like, "Hey, that
sounds kind of interesting. Let me hear
more." And depending on how good you are
with nurturing leads and booking them on
a calendar, I'm sure that will elicit
some amount of momentum. And you'll have
some people on your calendar actually
talk to. But nowadays, like obviously
since I've scaled up, I probably have
like I want to say like 40 to 50 inboxes
running at any given time. So obviously
it's a lot different now.
>> Nice. Nice. So like what is the what's
the golden standard? Like if you could
have I know there's lots of metrics and
as the funnel gets smaller, as you go
down each step, you significantly lose
more people all the way down, but let's
just say reply rate. What is like a
really really good percentage of reply?
>> Yeah. Yeah, that's a really great
question. So, let me give let me give
people like the reply rates that I look
at. So, typically if there's anything
under a 2% reply rate for me, I start
wondering if my lead list or my
deliverability is off, right? So, either
the inboxes are not landing in the
actual the the emails are not landing in
the inbox. Sellian spam or my lead list
is totally wrong. So I'm aiming at
architects but I'm talking to a bunch of
like contractors or something like that,
right? Because that's going to fall in
deaf ears.
>> Then if it's above 2% and below 5%, I'm
usually just worried about copy because
it probably means that you're you're
landing inside the inbox, but people
just are not responding because your
copy is not, you know, interesting
enough to actually respond to and
they're just ignoring it, right? And
then if you have anything above a 5%
reply rate, below a 10% reply rate, I
would say that's like the golden zone.
I'm not saying it's like a perfect reply
rate. There's people out there getting,
you know, 15% 25% reply rates, which is
fantastic and stuff like that. Yeah,
it's insane. But with a meaningful
amount of leads, like 3,000 leads, a 5
to 10% reply rate is more than enough to
get you a meaningful amount of pipeline
volume, right? Like enough leads that
are interested in what you have to say
so that you can eventually nurture a
good chunk of them and get them on a
meeting. And if you can get even 10 of
those people on a meeting and you have
like basically little to no sales
experience, I'm pretty confident that
you'll be able to like close one of
them, even if it's like for a really
small deal, right? So, I would say below
2%, look back at your lead list, look
back at your infrastructure. Above 2%,
below 5%, look at your copy and your
offer. Between 5 and 10%, you're
probably good. But if you really care,
then you know, keep looking at your copy
and offer and basically just make
everything a little bit better. And then
if you're above 10%, then um you know,
send me an email. I'd love to work with
you. Um, but yeah.
>> Hey guys, real quick. Just wanted to say
that I know we're covering a lot of
information in today's episode. So, I
don't want you to worry about taking
notes. I've compiled all of this into a
resource guide that you can access for
completely free. You can find that
inside of my free school community. The
link for that will be down in the
description. So, hop in there, grab that
guide, check out the other resources
that we have available in there, once
again, for free. And let's get back to
the video.
>> My lead process, just to get a little
bit more nitty-gritty, and I'll just
kind of glean over this really quickly,
is that I'll have AI find niche
databases because we already talked
about this. uh I'll have do do some
level enrichment. So I'll still use
Apollo to actually find the email
addresses and decision maker names and
you can obviously use like sales
navigator and amplify which is a massive
platform that people use nowadays as
well. I'll clean the data which is
really important. Uh don't forget this
step. Basically just go on to a website
called mill million verifier or any
mailinder and basically just make sure
those emails are real emails so that you
don't bounce and these this clean data
is really crucial because you don't want
to pay for all these domains and inboxes
and then have them all be destroyed
because you didn't send to a right the
right lead list. And I actually
personalize that scale. So I'll run an
automation. And my automation is like
stupid simple. It's literally just
attached to a Google sheet. That Google
sheet will feed perplexity relevant data
about that decision maker. So like their
name, their company. Perplexity was
prompted to create like a a robust
research report. It's pretty short
research report just like uh just the
things that I really care about. It'll
feed that into chatbt which is obviously
also prompted to make a really casual
personal sounding icebreaker. Icebreaker
is created and then boom, it's popped
back into the Google sheet. It's
literally I think when I first started I
made it make.com.
It's four modules long, so you don't
need anything crazy. And that's really
what got me to like zero to one to like
10 and so on and so forth. Um, and then
obviously I would set up infrastructure.
So like 30 emails from many domains
instead of 300 from one, but that's like
a more I guess like a closer look at all
that stuff, but nothing really new
there.
Um, moving on though. So here's a little
bit about like my copy and offer. And
I'm going to actually show the exact
copy I use as well. the I always treat
the subject in the first line as like
the things that are going to get people
to open the email, right? So like, okay,
cool. What can you say in the subject
line? I always try to treat the subject
line as what would somebody inside their
own team say to them, right? So like you
wouldn't want to reach out with them
like I wouldn't want to reach out to
them and say like, "Hey, I want to
create a cold email campaign for you."
Because they immediately know like, "Oh,
this guy's going to try and sell me
something." Right.
>> Yeah. I immediately I immediately mark
those as unread or as red.
>> Exactly. Exactly. But what I did, what
one of the things I did actually, and
I'll show you later, is like I would
create like these cliffhanger um subject
lines that make it sound like it's
either from someone on their team or
like a friend or a family member or
something like that, and it's just kind
of like a cliffhanger, so they want to
open it. And then the personalized line
goes to the very top because if it's
just like a a specific compliment like,
"Hey, I saw that recent project you did
with XYZ company. Really cool that you
did this thing." They there's like a bit
of like curiosity like, okay, they could
be reaching out to me about a plethora
of things. They could be reaching out to
me about, you know, inquiring about my
own business. Um, they could be reaching
out to me because they have a question
about this project I work on, all that
great stuff. And they, it just gets them
to open the email. And with that's all I
want them to do because the offer is
going to be the biggest part here. You
want to make sure that there's an
outcome, a time, and a catch. And the
way I think about offers is literally
like you have a desired outcome. So like
what's their desired reality within a
specific time frame and then basically a
risk reversal or guarantee if you're not
able to achieve that for them, right? So
I will get you 10 meetings on the
calendar in 30 days and if not you don't
have to pay me a dime. Right? So the
outcome is the meetings, the time is the
30 days and the catch or the risk
reversal is basically what happens if I
don't do that because that essentially
makes them lower their guard down and it
makes it a lot more likely for them to
want to talk to you, right? And then I
lead with the video. So the video is
basically my low low pressure ask
instead of like asking them for 30
minutes on their calendar. Um, I'll just
say like, "Hey, I have this video that
actually explains everything that's
necessary and they can I just send that
over? It's gonna be five minutes."
They're a lot more likely to say yes.
And I think the reason the video works
really well is because even though it
takes longer for them to book a meeting
with you, if they do book a meeting with
you, especially once they watch the
video, they basically know everything
about you and your offer. And selling is
so much easier. Okay, so let me go ahead
and talk about my copy from 0 to one.
This is literally the word for word
verbatim copy I used to get like my
first client and a handful of other
clients after that as well. So, the very
first one was cute. Is company name
taking on more clients or first name
cute? And basically, it's like a
question. I'll be honest, it's a little
bit of a bait and switch. I'm not going
to I'm not going to lie about that
because it sounds like I'm inquiring
about their business, but it it ripped.
Um, and basically, I would have the
icebreaker and I would say something
like, "Hey, saw you guys were just down
the street because I was going local um
location. Thought I'd reach out. Been
getting an agency up and running, which
I was. recently helped scale a local
business, Sarah's TNW, which is the
beauty salon, um, to six figures with
our AIdriven automations. Um, and
basically, I was kind of intentionally
ambiguous with the name as well because
if I said it was like a beauty salon and
stuff like that, they'd probably
immediately disqualify themselves in
their brain. And so I said, "Hey, I put
together something uh I think you'd find
interesting. It's basically a intent
based email scraping and outreach
system. We use to book 23 discovery
calls a month. Uh, would this be of
interest? You wouldn't owe me anything
unless it actually drives results. let
me know if I can send over a 90-second
video showcasing how it works or if you
want to just talk. Appreciate the time
and then I would sign off. And my second
email was Q from your neighbor. First
name Q from your neighbor, which again
is kind of like that little bit of like
that cliffhanger thing because it could
literally be about anything, especially
with the first line being personalized.
Bit out there, but we put together an
outbound tool that books over 20
meetings a month. No added headcount and
you don't pay till we deliver results.
Recently worked with a small business
near me and we built something similar
to help them break through a 10K a
month. Uh would love to send over a
two-minute loom talking about how it's
done. Thanks. PS, saw you were just down
the street in location when I was
looking into creative agency space cuz
this was targeted video agencies. Uh so
I had to reach out. Would genuinely love
your thoughts even if it isn't quite
quite the fit. Right. So I think so let
me just break it down like kind of like
the dissect it a little bit. So
obviously the top line is personalized,
right? And then I get straight into my
social proof especially in the lefth
hand email here which is Sarah's TNW six
figures. Basically just saying like I
I've worked with businesses before and
then I get into my offer. I try to
explain it as coherently as possible.
where I use intentbased data. So like at
the time what I would do is like I would
use like LinkedIn job boards where
companies were hiring for video agencies
and I would scrape a bunch of leads from
there for those companies because
they're essentially raising their hand
and they're saying like hey we need
video work done right and then I would
put my clients in front of them instead.
Um would this be of interest? You
wouldn't owe me anything. And that's
kind of the risk reversal, right? So I
have the desired outcome 23 book
discovery calls time frame is a month um
and then the risk reversal is basically
you don't pay us anything until it
drives results. The whole point of this
actually from the very beginning was to
get people to uh want to work with me
and I was going to do the work
completely for free until I actually
deliver results. Second one, very
similar thing. I just get straight into
the actual offer. 20 book meetings a
month. Uh no added headcount and then I
would I get into the social proof. Would
love to send over a two-minute loom
which is like the actual video. And this
is like literally the offer that I ran.
And I think a big uh part of this offer
that or this copy that worked really
well was this. We had I think for like
the last few years we just came off the
back end of people sending like these
kind of like um I don't know how to
spell like broy emails where they kind
of act like you know like I'm the top
dog like they would like send like
10-word emails and they would kind of
just like uh it was kind of like this um
assumed close kind of email, right? It
was like I already know you want to work
with me type of thing. And I think just
being honest and literally just
literally even if it like discredit me
saying like hey I'm just trying to get
an agency up and running. I don't have
that much experience. I would do this
for free. let me see, let me know if
your thoughts are right. Like kind of
coming at it from more of a humility
standpoint or a sincerity standpoint. It
actually I think it worked as like a
pattern disrup and I think it was really
refreshing to people as well. And so it
was like oh okay like
>> cool like let me let me like you know
let me give this guy a chance. Let me
talk to him. And I think coming from
that purview at the time worked really
really well. And so I know a lot of
people out there when they talk about
cold email copy they talk about like
writing in this really like stoic, super
markety, super punchy tone. Um which
100% works depending on your offer. But
I would not stray too far away from
writing emails that are kind of actually
personal and make you actually sound
like a normal human being and not just
like this massive faceless corporation
that's sending like you know uh 60word
emails and things like that. So let me
go ahead and move on to
basically stuff I wish I knew. So
firstly I would say even if you don't
have sales just start a project and
outbound will prove demand really really
quickly. So basically don't try and
overbuild or anything like that. just
use outbound because it's going to be
like really good direct market feedback.
And if people are not really listening
to what you have to say, people read
your email and they're like, "Okay, like
they're not responding whatsoever, then
either you're framing the email
incorrectly or the offer itself is not
that good, right? And so you need to get
really really good at that." If you go
on an email and you say, "Hey, I built
an 18 module NAD proposal system using
Gamma and Slack and all these other
things." Like even though it is
valuable, like business owners don't
really care about that stuff.
>> Nobody cares. Yeah. Nobody knows what
that means. Nobody cares.
>> Nobody cares except us, right? Like
we're like in a bubble basically.
>> But if you position in a very different
way, like, hey, I think I have a system
that's going to increase sales cycles by
like 23%. I think it's I have a system
that I think can increase your sales
closing rate by 15%. I plug it in for
your business completely for free. And
if it doesn't work out for you, then
hey, you don't have to pay me a dime.
Then they're going to be a lot more
likely to actually be interested. And
then you actually have proof of concept.
And now you can start building this out.
And now you can actually start putting
in businesses, right? And we have
there's tons of infinite resources
online to actually figure that out. I
would say like the minimal setup is you
just need a few tools to actually get
meetings from now on, right? When once
you get a meeting, then obviously you
need to have the wherewithal to take the
money that you got from that closed deal
and then reinvest it into the setup
because that's how you actually scale.
Uh talk to customers. That's the biggest
thing. If anyone takes away one thing
from this entire process, it's talk to
customers first and then build once they
actually tell you that they actually
value what what you're actually putting
in front of them. Um that way you're not
wasting time building things that nobody
actually wants or nobody's actually
going to sell or buy from you. Uh and
you don't have that sunk cost. And one
really big thing is um Aban's rough,
right? Uh people are going to say some
crazy things to you. Expect harsh
results, uh swearing, insults, mockery.
It's going to sting, but it's very very
normal. Um and it doesn't mean your idea
is bad and it doesn't mean you're doing
something wrong. It's just part of the
process, I would say. Um even if you
have a killer killer campaign, there's
going to be a lot of people that cuss
you out. I've had campaigns that have
almost like gotten 20% reply rates and
you know half of them are positive and
there's some there's still going to be
replies within that exact campaign that
are telling you like screw off.
>> Yeah, man. I think that's why people a
lot of people that try to do cold
outreach end up kind of quitting because
it's such a numbers game and because you
have to get through a lot of that stuff
that doesn't really feel great. And at
the end of the day, yeah, humans humans
are humans. But um what you talked about
with like talking to customers, I I
couldn't like repeat that enough. If you
think about like we've all fallen victim
to maybe a drop shipping ad or some sort
of impulse buy and it's all because
these companies are doing research to
understand what are the exact specific
pain points that people have. So that
way I can just chuck up an ad somewhere.
They have no idea about my brand or me,
but they're still going to buy because
that painoint resonates with them so
deeply. That's what it's all about.
>> Yeah, 100%. And the thing is sometimes
when you talk to customers, even if it's
revealed that your specific offer is not
that valuable to them, it's really easy
to segue that conversation into finding
a solution that is valuable to them.
Like I've had conversations with people
where I've positioned lead genen to
them. I've had a conversation with them,
they said it's not that valuable to
them, and then I literally just I just
pose the question like, "Okay, like is
there anything else that you do need
help with right now?" And they talk
about it and then boom, you're kind of
back in the game. And now you can
actually build something that they care
about, right? Yeah. Starting from
scratch uh from 0 to one, I would do
some free work. Don't build stuff nobody
wants. I chat with customers all the
time. That's going to be your most
important. That's going to be your high
highest leverage task. And I would find
a crowd by seeing who responds. Uh
that's like a big thing I also did.
Basically, when I got positive
responses, I would actually place them
all in a Google sheet and I would track
the company size, the industry, uh
general description of who they are, uh
who I actually spoke to. And what I
would do is when I built a new a new
lead list, I would use that as like my
frame of reference because I knew like,
okay, out of a thousand people I reached
to, these 10 people were the most
interested and they all have this, this,
and this in common. And that's how I
went from, you know, a 3% reply rate to
a 5% to an 8% to a 10% and so on and so
forth because I would keep just doubling
down on basically the people that were
actually interested in me.
>> Absolutely. I've got one final question
to end us off here and it's about data.
So earlier you talked a little bit about
metrics, about how many emails you send,
about what kind of, you know, KPIs
you're looking at. What I wanted to ask
you about to close off here is about
when you see all these numbers,
what do you actually do to let's just
say your copy or to your strategy?
Because I think the thing that really
separates winners from losers is that
everyone fails. Everyone goes through
challenges, right? And so the winners
are the ones that take those challenges
and look at the data and take the
learnings and fix something. And the
losers are ones are the ones that don't
change anything and just kind of expect
the system to improve. So if you could
give like one key takeaway of something
that you always watch and make sure to,
you know, optimize, what would that be?
Yeah, for sure. I would say data is
super duper important when you're trying
to iterate. And a lot of people only
focus on positive data, right? They only
focus on the positive responses as well
or one or the other honestly, just
negative or just positive. But I would
say that data is basically just a
compass towards the direction you want
to move in. If you have positive data,
positive replies, meetings, people who
close deals, it's basically a signal
from the market telling you, hey, this
is the correct direction to move in,
keep moving in this direction, right?
And if you get negative data, negative
like uninterested replies, people who
aren't booking meetings with you, people
who don't choose to close. It's not data
that isn't valuable. It's actually just
data telling you, hey, this is the
opposite direction of where you want to
go. Biggest point of data I always focus
on is going to be reply rates. So, how
many people are actually responding to
your email? Then I would focus on
positive responses. So, what percentage
of that is positive? I would focus on
what percentage of people are actually
either looking at the video. If you do a
video, like you can track it on Loom.
So, I always track how many people are
actually viewing the video compared to
how many people I send it. And then I
would track how many people are
converting into a meeting.
>> Yeah. And and I I love how you broke it
down because it's really important to
think about the steps in between. You
can't just think about a thousand emails
resulted in one client because in there
all the drop offs there's something
different you have to do to improve each
of those metrics. So it's really about
dissecting and you know actually going
through the journey of a customer and
you know making changes based on that.
So thanks so much for hopping in here
today Savom. Um you you gave us a lot of
good information. So I think that
someone now who's either starting out
with cold outreach or maybe they haven't
been doing it for a while has some
really practical steps to scale up and
get started there. So, where can people
find you if they want to work with you,
learn more about you?
>> Yeah, for sure. I really appreciate you
giving me the chance to talk. Um, so the
first thing I would tell people to look
at is not even my company. Uh, I'll you
have the gamma link, so they can
actually watch this video that I
actually broke down how I generated
$500,000 with cold email. I posted in
school, but it's on a Loom video, so
hopefully a lot more people can watch it
now. It talks about how I generate 700K
plus in pipeline at this point. Uh, it's
like a 1-hour step-by-step walkthrough.
It includes the infrastructure list
building and my exact script just like
the ones I showed you. I also do like a
quick community Q&A basically just as
answering questions that people have. So
hopefully it answers that as well. So at
the first and foremost like I want
people to get value from this. So
hopefully this sauce helps. Um and then
if they're actually interested in what I
specifically do, they can find me at
flowamation.co.
Uh this is my website at the very
bottom. You can also find me on LinkedIn
flowation as well, Instagram. And then
obviously you can always always email me
and I'll be the one to respond at
contact.co as well.
>> Awesome. Well, thanks again for taking
the time to hop in and share all these
insights with us. I really enjoyed
getting to meet you and getting to hear
about how you've been able to find so
much success through the cold email
game. So, thanks so much.
>> Yeah, thanks so much for having me,
Nate.
>> So, I hope you guys enjoyed today's
episode with Savon. If you're also
interested in checking out some cold
email techniques and growing an AI
automation agency, then definitely check
out my plus community. The link for that
is down in the description. We've got an
amazing community of over 3.5,000
members who are building businesses with
AI automation. So, it's a great spot to
be. Lots of other entrepreneurs in there
and lots of other people who are just as
obsessed with AI as you probably are.
So, I hope to see you guys in that
community. But, that's going to do it
for today. So, if you enjoyed the video
or you learned something new, please
give it a like. It definitely helps me
out a ton. And as always, I appreciate
you guys making it to the end of the
video. I'll see you on the next one.